good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday hey
Claude hy d good morning Jackie it's
Friday Friday gotta get down and ready
hey been literally like we woke up at
the same time he like rolled over and he
whispered in my ear it was like it's
Friday it's honestly crazy what like
cultural impact that idiotic song had on
me and an entire generation ya know it
was a moment for sure for sure but like
it also is Friday and I'm excited that
it's Friday even though we're still in
quarantine like the weekends are
starting to feel more and more
legitimate real and I really just like
I'm so excited to sleep in I can't even
tell you and just watch Potomac all day
all night so I have like a great weekend
ahead of me and I'm ready to embark on
it there was like a period in quarantine
where we were doing our show like much
later on like live at noon so I really
wasn't waking up to like 10:30 11:00 but
now that we're pre-recorded to speak
especially we've tried to do earlier
shows because people seem to like it so
I'm exhausted yeah no I agree like this
was the first week where I fell asleep
like when I went to sleep you know I
just like lay there contemplating the
Earth's biggest questions say no and
I've been going to bed at like 10:30
it's like it's I've been on a like
strict regimen it's like there's a Bravo
usually from 9 to 10 and then 10:30 10
to 10:30 s watched Rabin's live and then
boom I'm asleep like I cannot believe
how early I feel like a grandmother oh
that's really early I've been going to
sleep around midnight last night was
12:30 because I stayed up to finish
season 2 of Real Housewives of Potomac
I'd like a frog in my throat um I have
to watch the reunions which I'm really
excited about and then I'll be on season
3 so hopefully but next time you see me
I'll be on season 4 wow that's crazy
it's crazy what can happen in a weekend
you know it's crazy what can happen in a
weekend so we have a great show will I
have to make a correction real houses in
New York was on last night I'm so sorry
for sparing this information it's been
very confusing for a Bravo like no real
statement it's like why they're delaying
I'm actually read on like
Bravo groups that so much of their
production their future production is
delayed because of ko bids so they're
kind of just like spreading out the
fresh content that they still have I
don't know if that's true or not but it
made a lot of sense so I apologize there
was a real episode an episode of real
houses in New York and we will be
recapping it in our TV recap segment
along with some other things um we have
Fast Five some good some bad some very
sad stuff but some happy stuff yeah
actually I think we have some good news
I mean I think there's just like one sad
news story that hurts my heart but the
rest is relatively good news I think so
I'm excited about that
I actually I like the idea of Bravo
spreading out their content so that when
the time comes when the drought of
coronavirus 2020 occurs that we are
prepared so I'm okay to wait a few weeks
even though I will miss I will miss my
shows yeah even though like I was really
not looking forward to real houses in
New York but I'm glad we're gonna recap
it because I actually have a lot of
thoughts and it wasn't necessarily the
worst episode I've ever seen did you
watch last week's episode yeah I we have
to talk about last week's episode I was
in shock I've never seen a more
dysfunctional dinner and like not in a
cool interesting way like in a what is
happening right we'll get into it we
have so much to recap so I think we
should start Oh also if you haven't
listened to the latest episode of the
redheads it is available now we are
recapping Kootenai Moline and if a
little historical fiction is not your
speed get started on the newest redheads
book which is I Know Why the Caged Bird
Sings by Maya Angelou and then speaking
of books today's Friday which means we
are going to be highlighting a black
business which we spoke about last week
why we're gonna start doing that and so
in the in uh in conjunction okay with
the redheads episode we're going to be
highlighting a black owned bookstore
called boil tea bookstores they're based
in DC they have I Know Why the Caged
Bird Sings along with tons of other
books that you can read about and learn
about yet like I said they're based in
DC you could shop online its loyalty
bookstores calm the founder Hannah
Oliver Deb is a black and queer
bookseller who has spent her career
working to diversify the book industry
in order for it to better serve the
powerful communities of color and
queerness they aim to be the
mid-atlantic neighborhood spot for one
for wonderful books and unique
stationery gifts and programming um so
like I said you could shop loyalty book
stores calm they do have I Know Why the
Caged Bird Sings but they also have tons
of other books if you're not doing the
redheads or you're just looking for
books it's a great way to spend that
coin so loyalty bookstores calm is where
we got um I know my favorite things
because I read it on the Kindle but I've
started ordering physical copies of all
of the books that we choose so that I
can have a collection and also so I can
take photos for Instagram so I ordered
this one from loyalty books and it's
great if you guys have any
recommendations or any of our listeners
our black business owners please email
us you can reach us at hello at morning
toast show.com if you want us to include
your business all you got to do is email
us hello at morning Toshio calm or you
have a recommendation we would greatly
appreciate it so let's do it okay
without further ado let's get into the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast Oh first story of
the day the big news of the day Matt
James is the new bachelor get ready
ladies Matt James is looking for love
The Bachelor announced Matt James who is
28 as its next leading man making him
the franchise's first ever black male
lead rachel lynde's he made history as
the first black female lead of the ABC
franchise for season 13 on Friday
morning Good Morning America announced
James's new history-making role with a
statement from ABC saying their quote
privileged to have Matt as the first
black bachelor quote we know we have a
responsibility to make sure the love
stories we're seeing on screen are
representative of the world we live in
and we are proudly in service to our
audience the statement read this is just
the beginning and we will continue to
take action with regard to diversity
issues on this franchise we feel so
privileged to have Matt as our first
black bachelor and we cannot wait to
embark on this journey with him ok I
have three points one um it's important
to note that they're not skipping Claire
season it's gonna be Clair season and
then no one from Claire season is
getting chosen it's just automatically
Matt in January so for those wondering I
thought the same thing because like
Claire is just like so on
do that like that just would happened to
her I was but I actually I was wondering
and I thought that she was just gonna be
skipped over but I'm glad that you
clarified that thank you
to is important like of course this is
fabulous but it only is gonna be
fabulous if like everyone watches it
because ABC of course they claim to be
diverse but at the end of the day
they're just after the bottom line you
know if something doesn't perform well
they're not gonna do it again so it's
important that everyone watched this
season because it's one thing for them
to like make a step in the right
direction but if this is like look when
they gave it to Rachel and then they
never had in another diverse lead it's
like you're not really moving forward so
it's important that everyone watches it
will be recapping it I think this match
sure will be - um it's just important
that everyone watches it so that's what
yes they will be watching it and
recapping it so about third thing the
third thing I wanted to say is like what
didn't Mike Johnson do wrong like I
think it's crazy that they're having a
lead who's never been on the show before
um and of course these are unprecedented
times but it's like they went so far out
of their way not once but twice to not
give it to Mike Johnson who the people
seem to really like like I see a lot of
comments people rallying around him and
I know that there's been like rumors
that he's like weird but Peter was weird
too like oh yeah one is a little weird
so it's like why are they going so far
out of their way not to choose my
Johnson they're literally choosing
technically like a stranger to the
franchise even though he's Tyler seems
best friend he's never been on the
franchise before I just feel like what's
going on
why aren't they choosing Mike Johnson
yes I feel the same way and even though
I think Mike Johnson would have been a
great choice we did discuss how in
paradise like there was obviously
something weird with him when he stepped
on to the beach like he was so many
people's like first choice and then he
didn't really romantically linked with
anyone which made me think like he's
just kind of weird but or there's
there's a lid for every pot and just
because he might be a little socially
awkward doesn't mean that he can't be
the bachelor but I mean I do like that
The Bachelor they always say that
they're gonna do this where they're just
gonna pick someone who's not related to
the franchise yet they're like they used
to say they're gonna include Kardashian
to be the Bachelorette or like Amy
Schumer and so I actually like that
they're just starting clean
slate Matt James like I think a lot of
us have gotten to know his personality
from Tyler sees content and he seems
like a great guy and so I'm completely
here for this choice but I agree they
they are purposely have not chosen Mike
Johnson yet again but I think this is a
fabulous choice so I'm not going to harp
on on that well I'm gonna harp just like
for one more minute because it's just
confusing and I understand like he
walked on the beach in Paradise and was
like a little socially awkward but in my
mind I think that he thought he had a
real chance of being the bachelor and
didn't want to get into a relationship
and then like maybe have to break up
with someone like Nick did like I
thought I think that he thought it was
still a possibility and didn't want to
ruin his chances and I just can't stress
enough it's like anyone who's on TV and
looking for love is gonna come off weird
like I can't stress enough like okay so
they thought Mike was too weird so they
gave it to Peter who is the definition
of weird like have you ever seen his
chick talk no like here's the thing he
didn't Mike didn't even do anything
weird it was just just putting things
together like the fact that when he came
down to the beach like so many girls
were Ford when it came down to it like
nobody actually had a connection with
him the same way I felt about Benzie
when he went to Paradise he's my guy I
was like oh my god game over no there
was something weird about him because no
one I disagree yes no clay there's so
much that goes on like behind the scenes
like you have no idea why nobody clicked
with Mike Johnson I just think he's and
you know what it's like they said
they're they're catering to their
audience like the audience is not that
I'm at all unhappy with Matt James and
we've actually met him he's so nice and
so handsome
but I'm just curious like why they're
going so far out of their way to like
not give it to the obvious choice I
think that they're just starting fresh
like oh gosh James says it's like kind
of this person personality within
bachelor nation now without ever having
been on the show I think a lot of people
are interested in him and you know
obviously Bob Tyler see and so I think I
actually think that this is a choice
that really we're moving forward with
the bachelor franchise it's not just
moving backwards picking the person who
didn't get picked the last time and
apparently there was a reason he
depict okay I mean I would appear it's
my Johnson as well and like there was
just all that stuff remember like the
Demi Lovato comment and like oh my god
yeah he was doing like weird stuff but
he was I don't know like he was famous
like and he was excited you know even
though him asking keke palmer out on TV
was like not acceptable
but so I'm just I'm curious like what's
really going on behind the scenes as it
pertains to my Johnson because he really
not only now but also when they were
choosing for Peter season like he seemed
like the obvious choice
both times yeah but I guess they're just
trying to shake it up and I I'm here for
that me too Matt James is gonna do a
good job like he's super cute he was
supposed to be on Clair season but then
decided he's not gonna be unclear season
there was like drama between them she
like tweeted something shady towards him
cuz he was doing cameos before the
seasons premiered and she was like if
you're doing cameos and stuff before
like you even go on the show you're not
here for the right reasons
boy is she sorry yeah oh my god I can't
believe like I can't believe she's still
having a season Wow what like um a
Facebook comment okay but it felt like
it was real okay I mean I mean they
still need to cast it takes time so I
think it makes sense that Claire would
go first
they wouldn't disrupt the order of like
bachelor/bachelorette Bachelorette and I
think what I read was fair okay I think
that that sounds fair as well I'm very
much looking forward to Matt's season um
can't wait can't wait till and my and my
heart is with Mike Johnson like I'm sure
one that you know when people were
starting to have these conversations he
probably felt like it's gonna happen
yeah maybe he didn't want it maybe he
didn't want it
Oh see I like how we don't even consider
that like no one wouldn't want it um but
that's possible sometimes people don't
want it maybe he's like done with the
franchise you know he's yeah he's didn't
paradise he did Bachelorette and maybe
it's exhausting maybe he's in a
relationship
oh that's a good call you know there's
always like there's probably a lot of
things we don't know okay speaking of
relationships no no
story don't say some heartbreaking news
this is my heartbreak song Kelly
Clarkson files for divorce from her
husband Brandon Blackstock Kelly
Clarkson really is miss independent now
oh that is so mean throwing her lyrics
in her face the singer has filed for
divorce from her husband of nearly seven
years talent manager Brandon Blackstock
the blasts reported on Thursday she
filed to end her marriage on June 4th
Clarkson in Blackstock are the parents
of two children
surprisingly the songstress revealed on
her talk show in May that she wanted to
have more children but said her husband
did not feel the same way he also has
two kids with his ex they Wed in 2013
they recently put their California
mansion on the market and she previously
listed her Tennessee home reps did not
get back for comment I'm gonna go ahead
blaming it on the cue I'm laying it on
the queue they were quarantined in
Montana in like a house with one
bathroom and I I for some reason this
news didn't surprise me but like when
you file for divorce in June of 2020
quarantine brought you there no see I
think that quarantine is gonna take down
a lot of couples but I don't think it's
gonna take down as many marriages with
kids like they're just there were so
much more to lose and I don't think you
throw something like that away a family
I don't think you do that over
quarantine I mean there are blinds if
you wanna know what the blinds say it's
that now we've been on her and that's
why when I read the news like the blinds
have always been in the back of my head
but I just then you know the song the
lyrics to peace I think that was about
him you can't write a song about someone
that's like piece by piece and then not
be with them forever and then get
divorced I will never leave like you
left me and she will never have to
wonder her worth because unlike you I'm
gonna put her first and you know he'll
never walk away he'll never break her
heart he'll take
everything's love her
honestly if you've never seen Kelly
Clarkson on the American Idol season
finale on like five years ago singing
piece by piece when she's nine months
pregnant and getting so emotional like
go pause this show type into YouTube
Kelly Clarkson piece by piece and watch
how Keith Urban is sobbing like it's the
best performance ever and I'm really I'm
devastated I mean hopefully this breakup
will like have her tap into that piece
of her heart that wrote piece by piece
because she's like so devastated and
hopefully we'll get that'll be like the
only silver lining here but I'm just
curious if he's a talent manager is he
her manager they didn't say her manager
he said a talent manager yeah but
honestly if he's her manager he's doing
in a phenomenal job she is everywhere
these days I feel like she's tapping
into all of her strengths like just
within her personality being a boys
judge being a talk show host like she
like she's she's found her place in
Hollywood I completely agree which is
why as much as this story makes me sad I
feel like Kelly is the best Kelly we've
ever seen and if that means that she's
getting divorce and I think that and she
filed for divorce like this is what's
best for her now I'm sure Brandon
Blackstock is a nice man but like my
hardest with Kelly and whatever Kelly
needs is what I support so it Kelly
needs a divorce I'm here for it no we
are totally siding with Kelly yeah we're
signing with Kelly on this one it gets
us in the divorce yeah um I just I
couldn't believe it but I also I feel
like Kelly Clarkson is doing great yeah
no this is a symptom of her doing great
you know yeah but I was genuinely
surprised cuz I haven't really read the
blinds in a while and I had never read
anything about them and there are just
some people where you don't really like
think of their marriages they're just
like solid and then that's a fact of
life and for her for me she was one of
those people where it's like her
marriage was solid and that's a fact of
life and then when it just like was so
publicly like in front of my face like
they're broken up I was I was first like
my first emotion was just like sheer
shock yeah same blame it on the queue
okay like I have the itchiest back this
is disgusting I need to take my comb
ooh honestly having a scratch on your
back is one of the most annoying things
ever you have been scratching it for you
you scratched I have like a little bit
of like a sunburn on my back if you
scratch it back you need to scratch my
mine you need to get yours I need to get
mine so scratch DJ DJ come on bring it
just scratch dude we were just talking
about that do you guys remember that
itchy back oh you guys run with that
season of Kardashians
when Kim I mean Chris like pretend she's
gonna start managing like other clients
and she manages this girl group called
bg5 and she's like in the studio
listening to him sing that song scratch
DJ be nano oh man that just scratch dude
that was like iconic I wonder whatever
happened to the beach girls 5 I wonder
what happened I don't know
but speaking of bands Lady Antebellum
officially shortens their name to Lady a
quote we are sorry for the hurt this has
caused lady a put out a statement
yesterday revealing that they officially
changing their band which evokes a
painful time in US history they said as
a band we have strived for our music to
be a refuge inclusive of all we've
watched and listened more than ever
these last few weeks and our hearts have
been stirred with conviction our eyes
open wide to the end justices and
equality and biases black women and men
have always faced and continue to face
every day now blind spots we didn't even
know existed have been revealed after
much personal reflection band discussion
prayer and many honest conversations
with some of our closest black friends
and colleagues we have decided to drop
the word Antebellum from our name and
move forward as lady a the nickname our
fans gave us almost from the start well
this is obviously the right choice
because who wants like a name that
reminds people of like a racist racist
time in history but also I just think
that ladies a better name yeah I mean
this it's it's time honestly I didn't
realize until recently that Antebellum
meant before the war I thought
Antebellum was more of a geographical
location like south of the mason-dixon
line and I thought that it was um like
someone's last name
yeah Elam lady ashtray I feel like right
now everyone is kind of going through
some of the things that are in our
society right now that have these
connotations from slavery the Civil War
like the NASCAR just banned all
Confederate flags from their racetrack
which i think was an amazing decision um
and so I think this is a logical step
for them I think lady a is a cute name
of course I think some fans are still
like but the a stands for Antebellum um
you could swing maybe you could stand
for something else
Lady awesome yeah and that's you've
called them lady a forever
things are changing did you see and we
just spoke about it but I guess this is
conversations that have been had for a
really long time around band-aids yes
band-aids announced yesterday band-aid
brand an asked yesterday that they're
gonna have like four or five shades of
skin tones for their band-aids which is
long overdue but a step in the right
direction yeah so um proud of Lady a and
I think that's great news yeah and I
don't think it's really gonna change
like their fandom or their vibe like
they've always been lady a no but it's
just gonna change like the way some
people might have felt about hearing
that word Antebellum like celebrated of
course like that gave them a pit in
their stomach totally so I think it's a
great move next story a little
quarantine update from the couple
McCaffrey house um this week after 293
days living with her in-laws
Olivia cocoa returned to LA with her
sister MS and with Christians mom's do
Christians dad go No so I guess
Commission's dad was definitely I hear
having these people Christians that was
not here for the quarantine crew and
this um this whole development in this
story really gives air to that theory I
think like Lisa McCaffrey just like
loves live and they're going to LA
they're gonna be some la scenes and
Chris yeah they want to get I need some
space I feel like the mom I'd like lives
for the celebrity life and she like
definitely loves Olivia um and they want
to like go to Craig's and get like
paparazzi which I'm just I'm living for
for Lisa but
Lisa also lost her suitcase on the
flight did you see and she's going
through Olivia's closet like wearing her
stuff because she's delta lost her
suitcase
wait they to the commercial flight
that's really the big shocker here I
would have honestly flew private tough
times in the McCaffrey COPO households
Christian McCaffrey just signed a 64
million dollar contract jealous and they
flew commercial and his mom's bags got
lost you know really stars they're just
like us
ya know it's like some things are the
great equalizer that was like
coronavirus like no matter how famous
you are like you could still get it and
you know what losing commercial airline
like baggage is the great equalizer of
our time it happens to everyone it
happens to everyone but like and that's
actually really crazy that it happened
like I'm sure that they it was nobody on
the fly there was nobody on the plane
they probably flew like sky priority at
the very least either like Delta comfort
or first class and you usually get that
like get yellow take it on your bag and
there's no one on the plane like where
did her bag go crazy honestly so fishy
yeah like that's really crazy
things aren't adding up but she also
came home I'm like obsessed with bear
just family and she came home and she
had done all these renovations on her
house cuz she had just moved in so she
was like giving us all a house tour and
I say something controversial sure like
I love Olivia culpo when she was doing
her Instagram stories like before and
after of the renovation that she dad did
like let's say she did 10 Instagram
stories like 9 out of 10 of them I liked
what was there before better she
replaced like chandeliers and plans and
I'm like other ones were better it's
like super modern I don't know what that
style of house is I don't know and I
think it's like modern farmhouse yeah
it's like dirty tensley's house that was
described as modern farmhouse so now
everything's a modern farmhouse and yeah
I mean it's I don't know that that's
what I would have done but she probably
would hate what I would have done so ya
know it's you know interior design is
very specific I was just saying like it
wasn't my favorite okay
I love judging people's like million
dollar homes from like my rented
apartment you know yeah are you using a
comb to go through your eyebrows yeah no
I'm just like the same word I meet you
is used to sky
get back so it's really not fair you got
to get the Chapmans little paws in there
I know I actually wish Theo could
scratch my back like finally make
himself useful totally okay are you
ready for our fifth and final story that
will be a great way best I know we just
breeze through um it'll be great segue
into our TV recap segment because
Tinsley Mortimer will not return to the
real houses of New York this is her
fairy tale ending so after a lot of
questions surrounding her engagement her
moved to Chicago what is she gonna do
for Real Housewives of New York they
have made it clear that she is bidding
farewell to the Big Apple and to Baroni
Tinsley will not return to Roni the
reality star bid farewell to New York
with an Instagram post on Thursday night
additionally the show wrapped up her
storyline she was on watch what happens
live and he said it's her last time on
watch what happened side so her journey
as a Bravo Liberty is over and I just
have to say like I really respect the
hell out of the fact that she chose love
over Fame and celebrity yeah I feel many
different ways about this first I feel
um confused that they didn't make it
more of a storyline like even though she
left amicably whenever like when a
housewife leaves midseason like it's
always a big deal like I don't know why
it wasn't really treated like that it
seems like she left within a matter of
days there was no time to make it a big
deal
yeah I mean it did happen really fast
but now we're living in the future we
know that like they do actually get
engaged and she fully moves to Chicago
so like it's all good and fun um so
while I'm well I'm like happy for her
and like sad that she's leaving the show
I'm so grateful we're never gonna have
to talk about her relationship again
like Dorinda is gonna have to find
someone else to bully like of course
they were losing a cast mate it's sad
but like what Tinsley brought to the
table was really nothing and honestly
her vibe elevated the show but her
storylines have really brought it down
like for the last two season so I'm glad
we're never gonna have to hear about it
again okay I agree with you for the most
part but there were a few things that I
thought that I really liked about her
first of all the last conversation that
they had about Scott and I think it was
really Lea who turned the tide when they
were at the tea party and she was like I
saw Scott and honestly was great
but like I don't want to talk about it
because I know it's not gonna end well
and they were like if you love him and
it's great like go be with him like go
get your man like anything that was the
first time her friends have ever
encouraged her to be with Scott and I
think that that like that just one
moment of encouragement change her
mentality that was like oh I don't have
to punish myself every time I like feel
something for Scott like maybe I could
just embrace it and see where it goes
because clearly he feels something for
her too and they have a nice
relationship I also will say last night
I watched her happen side and II asked
her what do you think like you'll be
remembered for from Real Housewives and
her answer kind of stunk like cuz she
didn't get it out right but what she was
trying to say is like she never bullied
anyone like she was never mean to anyone
for no reason like she never got caught
saying something not like she had to
apologize for cuz she like she wasn't
mean and I think in the realm of real
housewives like that's an accomplishment
well you could call it an accomplishment
or you could call it boring no but like
I think it's that's merely the lowest
hanging fruit is just to like be like to
Rinna and dismiss people and say mean
things that are funny but Tinsley like
was never mean to anyone and I like she
just I think that that's kind of cool ya
know it's very cool but I actually think
it will result in her not necessarily
being remembered period and I honestly
think that tinsy will be remembered like
the worst phase of her life was Big
Apple Circus no no like the these four
years or three years like we're probably
the lowest points in her life between
moving to Palm Beach and getting EHS
Scott and like that's all we know of her
yeah but what she was saying on the show
before she sucked is like all and she
didn't say it like this but like the
shitty time I've had it you know
low-balling it on this reality show got
me to where I am now so like I'm
grateful for it it's like you can't have
that you know any success in life
without some adversity yes I agree and
ultimately like she could have been like
oh and Lucas Scott I'm new to Chicago
but my life in New York and she could
have gone back and forth on the decision
for months and he'd been even more
annoying but she she'd made a decision
and I respect decision makers you know I
know and it was the right decision it
was the right decision I really am happy
for her I'm happy that she got her
fairytale happy ending um and I like the
that her story wrapped up even though
she is annoying no she's not even
annoying she's just boring so I'm
grateful and that's how I have felt like
a lot of the season so far is just
boring and I have to assume it has
something to do with the most boring
cast made her so I just am looking
forward to maybe a more fruitful season
without her like we're just not gonna be
sidetracked by these dumb conversations
between her and her and uh I don't know
because now they showed the previews for
the next few weeks and right now I think
Tinsley like her role had become like
being like kind of a sidekick to lea and
like them just having like a really good
strong friendship and so the two of them
can kind of like bring the other women
to sort of I don't know she is on her
own and Lea's on her own and for that I
will miss Tinsley yes
um but let's dive into New York House
where I was because it was actually a
very good episode and it's become like a
trend on housewives to like have the
women on Halloween get scared and like
film each one of their reactions and
it's literally my favorite thing in the
world like they do that Kyle's Halloween
party last year and now they did it
outside blood Manor by the way I've
never heard of that place
me neither Dorinda said was an
institution sometimes I watched his show
and I'm like I don't even live in New
York City
totally but I kind of want to go to
blood man I just swung around you know
something so that night when they go out
to blood Manor and then they go out to
the tequila bar Anejo which like wasn't
just killing me like I wanted to be
there so [ __ ] badly like fighting
with my friends and having drinks um
Dorinda really um she exceeded my
expectations you know and I find her
doing that every episode like just when
you think she can't say anything more
[ __ ] up than the last episode she
tests Tinsley if she needs her turkey
baster you're gonna try and have a baby
like my jaw hit the floor like just when
he thought she couldn't go any lower she
says probably the most [ __ ] and and
I've said this now three times about her
this season but that is the most [ __ ]
up thing I've ever heard on housewives
yeah also like they were cool and
finally Dorinda was getting what she was
wanted which was for teacher and maid
Tinsley to admit that she's with Scott
and like the fan Tinsley said it a
million times but it's so true it's like
you only
want to hear about it when you know that
I'm miserable and when I'm actually
happy you don't want to hear about it
because you don't care about me
yeah and I'm on this struggle bus with
Dorinda this whole season between like
literally thinking she's the most evil
person in the world like some of the
[ __ ] that comes out of her mouth like I
can't even fathom how someone could
think something so evil about their
friend um but then also she has these
like really endearing moments like when
she got up from that horrible dinner at
Tinsley's friend's restaurant and just
like went home and I was like yes sir in
there like that's what I would do to
like sometimes like she really like
speaks me and then sometimes she is just
so so mean I agree I like that she got
up and left dinner but those moments are
few and far between now compared to how
mean she is and how much she takes out
her stuff on other people yeah and and
then by the way and I'm all for
understanding like she's definitely
going through something like with the
house and John but her behavior and like
taking out or her friends is so far
beyond like the line like she can't even
see the line it just it honestly like
it's horrible like I couldn't believe
what she said about the turkey baster
like it was the most I don't even have a
word other than mean it was cruel it was
evil like I who thinks like that yeah
she's so mean and also all these women
are like perpetually going through stuff
you know like they're all not where they
thought they would be at this stage in
their lives yeah it's no longer an
excuse no it's no longer an excuse and
like Cher like taking out like your
personal [ __ ] on other people that it's
just like so ten years ago um
probably my favorite part of the episode
was when they went to the party planners
house and lung warehouse in Long Island
and how do we know that person did he do
what he did solicit Gorga's prey
yeah he's becoming like the residential
housewife party planner when they were
just chowing down on all of that candy I
was like this is incredible no when they
were taking a picture at the end and to
read it was like oh I know why we're
here we drove an hour to be in a promo
pic like for sure like for their
Instagram story like you know he's
giving [ __ ] a discount like that is
just so funny and I loved that whole
moment like of them and that terribly
awkward uncomfortable
photo ya know that was really funny
I agree my candy looks so good like
those pins of chocolate like chocolate
pretzels like the chocolate but they
weren't letting remote a Sonia and
Dorinda even talks like what else are
they gonna do besides eat and they were
like commenting on how much you were
eating wasn't really bothering me it was
so funny there was so much candy what
else you gonna do no it looked delicious
it really did um two things I wanted to
note when Sonia went into century 20
once in a meeting and she was like so
giddy and so excited like I actually
felt really happy for her because like
Sonja Morgan brand like it's having a
hard time like getting off the ground
and century 21 is like just what she
needed and so when the guy was like
talking her and she was like literally
trying not to like jump for joy it was
so cute yes
I am loving I'm loving Sonja yeah she's
like flip-flopping a lot like sometimes
she's so right and then she just takes
the wrong side because she like wants to
be on like Dorinda side I don't
understand her sometimes yeah um the
last thing I wanted to say is like
Ramona it's like obviously listening to
all the call her daddy drama because
she's in the car like with this guy on
the phone with to some guy that she's
dating and she's calling him boat man
and she like obviously wants to have
like a mysterious suit man type of fella
and it's like boat man it's just like
not it and I was that guy who showed up
at t-bar boat man oh I don't know but oh
my god the t-bar scene was making me
like salivate with wanting to go for a
drink pizza and the pizza the pizza
I was literally salivating also when she
was talking to Bowman I thought she was
just like on like a we just took a call
about like a guy for a boat so I don't
even know that was meant to be romantic
oh no she was trying to be like Carrie
Bradshaw big you know like it was just
not working no I didn't even register it
that's how little it was working um okay
yeah agree oh I want to talk about LuAnn
and her show and Sonja because Louie I'm
like really means on Sonja for like some
comic relief in her show and at first I
was like okay cool like people love
Sonja you get it like you're gonna
incorporate her into the show but like
she's not paying Sonja I thought well
LuAnn said she was and then Tarina said
I mean Sonja said she wasn't so I don't
know what to believe I feel like I'm
gonna believe the person who is or isn't
getting paid like and that's what Sonja
well so I think Sonja Sonja said she
pays for half of my glam so I feel like
the Paycheck that she gets it's like
let's see Durand is good let's say
Sonia's climb is $500 man pays her a
paycheck of 250 so technically like
she's getting paid but it doesn't even
cover her cost of like showing up to the
place are you joking that's insane luan
already has hair and makeup there that
she's paying for Sonia's hair and makeup
should be free and then Sonia gets paid
on top of that to like strip and make a
fool out of herself for luan show and
like do all of this heavy lifting that
is and I would understand if it was just
like one show in New York Sonia's gonna
be especially that's like you don't pay
people nobody like the door but go like
that is truly the craziest thing ever oh
and she's supposed to pay for half of
her makeup right I mean I don't know
this tour I guess should have been going
on right now we're like coming up it's
obviously getting Delana I don't know if
it ended up working out between Sonja
and LuAnn but I'd be very interested to
see also them auditioning those comics
was finally like but to to audition for
stand-up is like so great but to do it
on the TV show was like even breathing
I thought Mead you good yeah you never
know how they're gonna edit you like
Luann's passed about like they gave the
comics a rough edit like they might have
been funny but in the edits they surely
weren't so I thought they were very
gracious to these comedians yeah I
really liked it I just hope that like
Sonia gets paid fairly because that
bothered me and also when LuAnn went to
UM lunch with that guy who's like
directing the show um they were just
talking so like disparagingly about
Sonja and it's about it's like you're
about to like put your show on her back
not pay her and like talk [ __ ] about her
[ __ ] that that guy is like living for
the moment you know like is everything
for him so we have to give him a little
grace yeah we didn't talk about Leah but
once again Lee is just like everything I
need in a housewife in a human he needs
no explanation no and whenever it's her
verse anyone else like I am on Leah side
me - she's just like it's weird when she
gets so out of control because when
she's herself like she is the most like
to the point well-spoken articulate and
I get why she feels the need to release
and it's just so hypocritical these
women like acting so ghastly
like them them in Newport in the middle
of a restaurant with the fruit and the
hitting on the random guys like that was
so abhorrent the fact that anyone could
think that that was even close to what
leo is doing in a field with her friends
with no one else around like they're
just they're the hunchbacks who can't
see their own hunches no that was so
crazy and like I get it Lee as behavior
is extreme sure and maybe if she was
like in a different situation like you
could call her out on it but like for
Ramona to be like we're embarrassed by
you
when it's like you're the most
embarrassing person ever horrifying
horrifying and I think that's why Lee is
so upset a member of few weeks ago there
was all that Instagram drama
I feel like Ramona has tried to
perpetuate like this stigma of Leah from
filming to after that she's
quote-unquote embarrassing like Avery
was posting that on her Instagram like
mom you're associated with is so
embarrassing but it's like leah is not
embarrassing and I'm sure she's getting
annoyed that everyone keeps calling her
at Ramona
is embarrassing yeah yeah okay I'm glad
we're on the same page great figures oh
yes oh I totally forgot and I also have
one more thing before we dive into it
and figures um did you see that today
Netflix released a 25-minute Dave
Chappelle special I saw that briefly but
I haven't seen like I haven't watched it
obviously so I don't know if it's on
like Netflix app I'm sure it is but I
watch the whole thing on IG TV and it's
so funny because like a few days ago me
and Ben were just like talking about the
current state of the world and like the
black lives matter movement and I'm like
you know what like I really would be
curious to hear what Dave Chappelle has
to say cuz he's like such a powerful
voice in the black community and he's
always like making just like fire points
and like these funny roundabout ways and
I'm like too bad we'll never hear from
him because he just like doesn't he does
have social media he like does a special
once-a-year and then he goes back to his
house in Ohio but I guess he felt
compelled to release something and I
won't spoil it for anyone I'd to say
like it wasn't funny like it was serious
like I don't know if you could call it a
comedy special because three times it
was just like he's very impassioned and
he's angry and it was very very well
done but it's really not like funny
okay I'm gonna watch it but that's I
would have assumed it was like a comedy
special but it's yeah but so they like
filmed it outdoors with um they showed
you in the beginning like how they
everyone ready everyone had to wear
masks all the chairs were 6 feet apart
they took everyone's temperature when
they arrived it was really like a crazy
what he was talking about was like so
crazy and like the show itself like the
circumstances were so crazy I think
everyone should watch it it was really
really good okay
cool we'll do we could be on Monday but
now for hidden figures which I watched
last night so did you lose your first
time seeing it what did you think I mean
this was my face the whole movie ready
like everything was just so fabulous um
I don't even know where to start I
thought like the the vibe of the movie
was like so everything you know like in
their outfits like the music there at
the house it's literally just like the
way it's a historical movie based on a
real book and so you bring like a
history movie you don't associate with
like just being so fabulous yeah I just
loved the three women like I couldn't
decide who was my favorite like was it
Dorothy or was it mayor like everyone I
was just like living for all of them um
and you know what I was thinking I'm
like why is this movie so good and it's
like that genre of movie where it's like
this really happened but like nobody
talks about it
and it's so unbelievable a that had
happened and B that nobody talks about
it that the movie is so good it kind of
reminded me similar to like argh oh this
is so unbelievable it actually happened
but nobody knows about it so it's like
that genre I haven't seen Argo it's very
upsetting honestly I know spit the whole
time yeah okay but yeah that type of
genre genre I agree it's so amazing to
like watch a story that it's amazing and
then you find out it's a true story
that's how we felt about our redheads
book this month um but I want to talk
about something because I had seen some
comments on her Instagram and then I
looked into it that there's um some
controversy with the movie because it
has a white Savior in it so the
character that Kevin Costner plays did
not exist in real life I think it might
have been a composite character just
someone that the studio added and there
are two like key moments where he's you
know the white Savior and they didn't
happen
the first is the bathroom and it turns
out that Katherine Johnson just used
whatever bathroom that she wanted to
like that whole bathroom storyline
um wasn't real and wasn't necessary and
I think I guess they put it in to like
make white people like look good and
feel better about themselves which is
just like so unnecessary and also just
as a history person I hate when there's
a true story and they add elements that
are untrue for absolutely no reason that
nothing that like moves just for no
reason like I just think that it's
historically irresponsible um and then
the second thing oh when um when she
comes back to watch Glen Powell go to
the moon John Glenn John Glenn Powell to
circle the earth um she acts and then
like Kevin Costner opens the door and
lets her in that didn't happen so it's
just like another white Savior moment
she watched it from like her desk she
didn't watch it from inside the room so
it's just like these moments that I
guess I was reading about an article
about it there in attendance like make
white audiences just feel better about
the story
um which is disappointing because it's
just unnecessary like the story's not
about him whatsoever like we are here to
like watch race these three women make
history know what's frustrating about it
it's like the story was obviously
unbelievable enough for it to be made
into a movie like why do you have to add
all these narratives and you know I knew
going in that Kevin Costner's character
wasn't real so I didn't really connect
with him I was just like thinking I'm
like I wonder what actually happened
like why was this necessary and honestly
her using whatever bathroom she wanted
is such a better more powerful storyline
like I'm so upset and I it's just it's
so unnecessary like if a movie is good
enough if the story itself is good
enough to make it to a Hollywood studio
like leave it alone right and I do think
that when you're saying something is
based on a book like you should stick to
that as much as possible um because you
like I don't like when hysterical and we
talked about this I don't know if we
talked about this privately or on the
show with hunters and the controversy
with that show was about but I'm sure
like adding things to a historical show
or film that didn't actually happen in
it it takes away I think that it takes
away and it leaves the audience um
wrong about what actually happened and
it like leaves the whole narrative up
for interpretation when
certain elements aren't true and like D
values the the message and the storyline
and it's just it's so unnecessary like
her like not only was then adding that
bathroom narrative so a necessary the
truth is actually more interesting yes I
completely agree so that would be very
disappointing yeah that that's like um
something from the movie that I didn't
like but overall I absolutely loved the
movie and I to me it's it's about the
three women like whether Kevin Costner
opened the door didn't open the door
like these women were so incredible when
honestly I've seen this movie before
it's one of my favorite movies um but
when when it and didn't they were
showing like and I also got my period
yesterday but when they were showing
like the true stories and the pictures I
was crying and I see full-body chills
and like it was such an amazing story
there were two moments that real
actually three moments that really
really struck me first of all when she
came home from such a long day at NASA
and mashallah
Ali was there and cooked her dinner with
her family and asked her to marry him
like I just about died like it was I
wish when we've gotten it seems like
they had just met so like I wish we got
like a little bit more of like their
time together because it seemed like
they met it at that at the church lunch
and then got engaged but I'm sure that
there was more to it than that the
second thing that like really like shook
me completely was when Janelle Monae
fought in court to be able to take
classes at the all-white school and she
gets it and she like walks out of the
courtroom and she's just like jumping
for joy screaming it was just everything
of the story like I was literally like I
was Ben was like are you okay I was in
my ten I'm like yes I'm I get it yeah
it's like I was just living for it and
then also the third moment was the
credit um I just that's my favorite part
of like most historical movies it's like
seeing the pictures in real life I'm
like what they accomplished after the
movie quote-unquote ends and it was just
really really powerful stuff and it's
just so crazy how it's like these three
women like are responsible for like the
greatest accomplishment in American
history and up until this movie came out
like nobody knew that and nobody was
talking about it they were hidden
figures duh yeah
that also Jim Parsons has become this
like token actor for like the terrible
person like he was that person in the
Pauline in Hollywood on Netflix and I
just [ __ ] hated Paul his character I
just wanted to punch him he wasn't that
smart Catherine was smarter than him and
he just like thought he was so great
because he was a white man and he was
just like the symbol I don't know what
was his character real oh I don't know I
don't think so he but he was the symbol
of you know the light represented all
that was wrong in the country at the
time and a specifically in NASA yes and
Octavia Spencer was just like like the
mother of the girls and she was like
when everyone was getting their
assignments and like she couldn't get
that [ __ ] supervisor all because
kirsten dunst was being a [ __ ]
like I was just like feeling first so
hard but she said something so powerful
in the car she's like I'm happy that you
guys got your permanent um positions
because like a step forward for you guys
is a step forward for all of us and like
she was just really like she was a team
player but she got it at the end like
she got that supervisor role for the IBM
machine and I was just like living for
her know living for her it's amazing
yeah I can't believe that such a good
movie
I don't know if we're doing like toast
movie of the week ratings but that gets
a 5 out of 5 yeah no it's as good yeah
it gets a four point eight for the white
Savior [ __ ] like come on yeah that's
true
okay cool well that's all she wrote
thank you guys so much for listening
through to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show we where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that's Spotify I can stitch your
public radio I already know Cass box all
the places so ever you listen to podcast
find us morning to testify star review
about a beautiful studying and smart we
are we love you guys so much have a
fabulous weekend and just have a drink
bye have a great weekend bye